si el presidente joe biden ha querido
ver en primera persona cuáles han sido
los destrozos y los daños económicos
provocados por esta última tormenta
tropical por eso esta mañana viajaba a
new yersey por la tarde a la cia aquí a
nueva york la primera vez como
presidente de los eeuu se reunía con la
gobernadora kathy hochul y con el
alcalde de la ciudad de nueva york bill
de blasio para recorrer el barrio de
queens uno de los más castigados por
estas inundaciones allí fallecieron 11
de las 13 personas que perdieron la vida
la semana pasada por esa tormenta
tropical y durante su visita aprovechado
para impulsar su plan de
infraestructuras un plan de
infraestructura destinado a ayudar a
todas aquellas personas que han tenido
pérdidas económicas y tremendamente
castigadas por estos efectos
meteorológicos de hecho justo antes de
su viaje a nueva y asia nueva york la
casa blanca enviaba al congreso un plan
de financiación valorado en cerca de 14
mil millones de dólares para
precisamente ayudar a las personas
perjudicadas por estas tormentas o
huracanes ahora y en el futuro durante
su discurso job aiden ha hecho mucho
hincapié en la crisis climática ha dicho
que esto es un código rojo que las
situaciones preocupante que la nación y
el mundo entero está en peligro y que
está en nuestras manos que esto no vaya
a peor ha dicho que ni siquiera los más
escépticos esperaban que la situación
fuera tan grave hemos escuchado a un
presidente muy comprometido con el
cambio climático y de hecho por eso la
semana que viene visitará california
para ver cuáles han sido los efectos
devastadores de los incendios en esa
costa del país